السلام عليكم مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا
بكم معنا تغطتنا مستمره للتطورات
المتسارعه في السودان القتال العنيف بين
وحدات الجيش بقياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان واحداه التدخل السريع بقياده
الجنرال محمد حمدانلو لليوم الرابع حرب
البيانات بين فريق البرهان والجنرال حميطي
لا تتوقف العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تحت
دوير رصاص وقصف المدافع واعمده الدخان
الكثيفه تكسو سماءها واوضاع انسانيه مزريه
وتحضيرات امميه من تفاقم الاوضاع تشير هنا
الى ان قوات الدعم السريعه تتحدث عن وقف
مؤقت لاطراك النار والموافقه على هدنه
لمده 24 ساعه
[موسيقى]
اقسم بالله العلي العظيم يا السودان نحن
الدمار ده والله شايفين الدمار
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
اقسم بالله سودانيه احنا
يعني جاي وقتلوا اصحابي وكلهم يعني السيره
ذاتي قادر نرجع البيت ما اعرف نعمل شنو
جيت هنا جيت ما عارف جيت ليه
دمار
والله دمار دمار اقسم بالله
والله والله يا سودانيين احنا اقسم بالله
والله والله
[موسيقى]
الله يفتح عليك
طيب
هذا هو تم اخلاء مركز الشهيد سلمى لغسيل
الكلى بعد اصابته بمقذوف مع الدائره توقفه
عن العمل مع العلم انه الوحيد وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم الذي يقوم بتقديم خدمات غسيل
الكلى مجانا للمواطنين
كما حضرت لجنه اطباء السودان من ارتفاع
معدل القتلى والمصابين بين المدنيين مع
استمرار شراسه المعارك بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لفتاه تقرير اللجنه
الى صعوبه اجلاء وحصر عدد القتلى
والمصابين بالاضافه الى العالقين وقالت
اللجنه ان عددا من المستشفيات توقفت عن
تقديم خدماتها اثر تعرضها للقصب وانقطاع
الكهرباء
ورفضت تقرير استغلال العناصر المتحاربه
للامدادات
الطبيه كرتكازات معتبرته جريمه انسانيه او
جريمه انسانيه واخلاقيه ودانت اللجنه
الحرب الراهنه وناشدت المتقاتلين بفتح
ممرات امنه لمعالجه المرضى والمصابين
وايصال المخزونات الغذائيه الطبيه
لمستحقها
حسب مصادر العربيه من الاجتماع المغلق
الذي تحدث فيه فولكر بيرس الممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده بشان السودان
لاعضاء مجلس الامن فان احداث مروي كانت
القشه التي قسمت ظهر البعير ولم تكن سببا
لبدء نزاع المسلح على حد قوله المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان
مجلس الامن ان الجيش والدعم السريع قام
بالتعبئه منذ اسابيع وان كلا الطرفين ليس
على استعداد حاليا للدخول في اي مفاوضات
وفيما يتعلق بالهدنه الانسانيه قال بيرس
ان قياده قوات الدعم السريع غير قادره على
منح التعليمات لقواتها بسبب انعدام
الاتصال بين عناصرها المبعوث الامم يشدد
على انه في حال استمرت الاوضاع في التصاعد
سيضطر الى سحب الموظفين الدوليين من
دارفور الى الخرطوم واوضح بانه لا توجد
خطه حاليا للخروج من البلاد خاصه ان
المطار متضرر وعاطل عن العمل وشدد ايضا
بيرس على اهميه الوصول لهدنه انسانيه تمكن
من توصيل المساعدات الى محتاجها من
السودانيين
بعدد العمليات او المشاريع التي تم
ايقافها لا يمكنني اعطائك اي ارقام محدده
حول قيمه الممتلكات المسروقه او الامدادات
المنهوبه او حتى المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب
القتال كما قلت في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف
لا يمكن ان يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل
اساسي
لقد اجيت اتصالا هذا الصباح بكل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والفريق محمد
دقلو حميدتي ودعوتهما لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه فان وقف اطلاق النار من شانه
ان يشكل اساسا لعوده المفاوضات نتواصل معا
نظرائنا من الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا
بشان السودان لقد تعرضت قافله دبلوماسيه
امريكيه ام مثل اطلاق نار في السودان لكن
جميع الافراد بخير وهذا التصرف طائش وغير
مسؤول
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك ماذا في جديد
التطورات
اهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين اخر
هناك خدنا مقترحه من وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
حينما
هاتفيا او
تواصل مع
رئيس قوات قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان وقد تعهد
قائد الدعم السريع بفتح مسارات الامنه
لعبور المدنيين واخلاء الجرحى
ووافق على الهدنه المقترحه لمده 24 ساعه
التي صدمت في هذا الصدد اعتبارا منفجر امس
الاثنين كما اثر اكد على انه
يجب على انطونيو ان يتواصل مع الطرف الاخر
الذي لديه تفلتات بحسب وصفه وانه مازال
يقصف بالطائرات ويوجه طائراته بضرباته في
المناطق الماكوله بالسكان ويرى ان هذا
تجاوز سافر لاسس ومبادئ القانون الدولي
والانساني هذا ابرز ما ورد يعني في الصفحه
الرسميه قبل قليل على تويتر وعلى فيسبوك
لقائد الدعم السريع الذي تحدث عن موافقته
على المهله 24 ساعه لكن الطرف الاخر لم
يوافق الى الان الجيش السوداني لم يرد على
هذه
المهله ل24 ساعه التي جاءت مقترحه من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ووافق عليها الدعم هل
يمكن تحديد الطرف المسؤول عن افشال هذه
الهدنه
هي بعد الان هي يمكن
ما زال هناك فرصه لان تكون قائمه اذا رد
الجيش السوداني بالموافقه على 24 ساعه
فربما بعد ذلك تحدد بدايتها ونهايتها بعد
هذه المساعي من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
لاجل ان تتحرك
المساعدات الانسانيه لان الوضع الانساني
حقيقه
حرج جدا في هذه اللحظات ماذا عن خريطه
المعارك الان في العاصمه الخرطوم يعني في
اي المحاور تتمركز هذه المواجهات
والاشتباكات
نعم هذه المواجهات متفرقه الان في انحاء
متفرقه من الخرطوم وام درمان وبحري ابرزها
تتمركز في منطقه المظلات هنا في بحري فيها
وايضا في كافوري تاتي الطائرات محاوله قصف
المناطق التي فيها قوات الدعم السريع وبعد
ذلك ياتي الرد ايضا محاولا لاسقاط هذه
الطائرات
بمجموعه من
يعني مضادات الطائرات باشكالها وانواعها
حقيقه واصفاتها قويه للغايه ايضا
الطائرات تتوخى الحذر في
القصف الذي توجهه وهذا واضح من تحركات هذه
الطائرات لكن لا اظن ان مضادات الطائرات
تتوخل حذر في مقذوفاتها وهذا امر ايضا
مؤسف للغايه ايضا من خلال المشاهدات انه
الان هناك اشتباكات في محيط القياده
العامه مطار الخرطوم الدولي القصر
الجمهوري كذلك ايضا في ام درمان كذلك في
ناحيه ابو سعد وكذلك في المهندسين منطقه
المتقاربتين بهما اشتباكات ايضا
ودوي الرصاص وكذلك المقذوفات وكذلك
المدافع باشكالها يعني ذلك ان هناك مناطق
جديده دخلت في هذه المواجهات في العاصمه
الخرطوم
نعم هي ليست جديده لكنها لم تكن يعني نشطه
في الايام الماضيه مثل كافوري مثلا هذه
واصبحت نشطه منذ امس ايضا منطقه المظلات
كانت في اليوم الاول لكنها يعني لم تكن
نشط على نشطه اليوم لكن هي ليست هناك
مواقع جديده لكن فقط تزيد الوتيره في مكان
وتنخفض في مكان اخر
في البعد الانساني ايضا سالم كيف هي
التطورات في ضوء يعني فشل هذه الهدنه حتى
الان خاصه وانها كانت تتحدث عن ضروره فتح
ممرات انسانيه بناء على المقترح الامريكي
الوضع الانساني حقيقه مؤشر للغايه لان
قضاياه شانه جدا
فيما يتعلق بالموضوع الصحي فيما يتعمق
بالمواد الغذائيه فيما يتعلق كذلك
بالامدادات اللوجستيه المتعلقه ايضا
بالاطباء
وكذلك
المعينات التي يحتاجها الاطباء والان هناك
اصوات لمضادات الطائرات وانا اتحدث معك
هنا في منطقه بحثي استمع اليها الان من
الناحيه الشرقيه والغربيه كذلك من مدينه
بحري استمع الان الى هذه المضادات وهي
محاوله وايضا هناك طائرات في سماء منطقه
بحري هل يمكن تحديد الجهه ولو بشكل تقريبي
لانطلاق هذه المضادات الارضيه في اي منطقه
تقريبا من الخرطوم
في منطقه كافولي في هذه المضادات تنطلق من
منطقه كافوري وايضا تنطلق من المظلات
وايضا هناك من جهه امدرمان ايضا مضادات
لا اعلم او لا يمكن او لا يمكنني تحديد
المكان بالضبط في ام درمان الان في هذه
اللحظات على كل حال بالنسبه للوضع
الانساني الوضع الانساني حرج يحتاج الى
وقفه حقيقيه من المجتمع الدولي من
المنظمات من كل الناشطين والعاملين في هذا
المجال في مجال حقوق الانسان لان الوضع
ينبي بكارثه اذا ما استمر بهذا الشكل اذا
لم تفتح الممرات الامنه
لخروج المحتجزين لدينا الان قصتين
مختلفتين في موضوع الاحتجاز هذا خرج فقط
من المحتاجزين الذين خرجوا هم كبار السن
الذين كانوا في مستشفى
مستشفى غسيل الكلى في الخرطوم خرجوا
بالامس لكن بقيه المحتجزين ما زالوا في
اماكنهم قضيه طلاب جامعه الخرطوم 89 طالب
ما زالوا محتجزين حتى اللحظه في جامعه
الخرطوم
وقد قتل واحد من هؤلاء الطلاب في داخل
الجامعه بالامس بسبب
بلقناري وتواصل زملائه مع ذوي وتم دفنه
داخل الجامعه
لانهم لا يستطيعون الخروج ولا يوجد مكان
تحفظ فيه الجثه فاضطر لدفنه داخل الجمع
وما زالوا محتاجين حتى هذه اللحظه مثل هذه
القصص المؤلمه حقيقه تجعل الوضع الانساني
يحتاج الى تدخل لاخراج العالقين من
الاماكن التي هم عالقين فيها كذلك لايصال
المساعدات للمستشفيات لضمان وصول الكادر
الطبيه للمستشفيات لمواصله اعمالها لان
المستشفيات الان باتت تخرج من الخدمه
واحده تلو بسبب عدم وجود الخادم الطبي
بسبب انقطاع الادويه عن هذه المستشفيات
حتى من الغريب انه اصبحت الان نشاهد حملات
في السوشيال ميديا لمجموعه من
دوري المصابين يعني
يطلقون حملات غريبه جدا تدل على ان هناك
انقطاع حقيقي فيه العديد من المستلزمات
الطبيه الان هناك مثلا حمله تطلق ليسال
احد في السوشيال ميديا عن مستشفى توجد به
خيوط لخياطه جرح لاحد المصابين لان
مستشفيين ليس بهما خيوط
لدواء
لتضميد هذه الجراحه هذا امر حقيقه مؤسف
لانه انقطعت البلادات الطبيه انقطعت
الادويه للوصول والمستشفيات اذا استمر هذا
الحال بهذا الشكل فسيؤمري بذلك انسانيه مع
الاسر ازمه المياه ايضا يتم الحديث عن شرح
في المياه ربما
استهداف لبعض المناطق الحيويه
وكذلك انقطاع التيار الكهربائي كيف يتعامل
السودانيون مع كذا
نعم منذ امس ايضا منذ فجر اليوم وليل امس
بدات ايضا تعود ازمه الكهرباء تعود الى
السطح بعد ان كانت رجعت جزئيا في بعض
المناطق ها هي الان تعود
بالانقطاع في اماكن عديده جدا من العاصمه
الخرطوم اما المياه فهي منذ اليوم الاول
لاندلاع هذه الحرب قد توقفت مياه الخرطوم
تماما لا يوجد ولا قطره ماء في بالنسبه
للمواطنين في بيوتهم اضطر المواطنون الى
ان هناك ابار معينه وايضا خزانات كبيره
فيها مياه في مناطق مختلفه في مؤسسات
مختلفه اضطروا لان يحملوا
المواعين والادوات التي يحملون فيها
المياه الى البيوت يدويا
ومازال هذا الامر حتى هذه اللحظه يعني حتى
هذه اللحظه موضوع المياه لم يجد حلا لكن
وزير الداخليه اليوم كان قد
ودها اداره الدفاع المدني بان تبدا في نقل
المياه
للمواطنين في الاحياء وللمستشفيات كذلك في
مناطق مختلفه لانه كثير من المستشفيات
وضعت واحد من الاسباب الرئيسيه لاغلاق
ابوابها لاستقبال المرضى والمصابين هو انه
لا توجد مياه في لا توجد مياه حتى الان
سالم هل تم تسجيل دخول اي اطراف او
مجموعات مسلحه في هذه المعارك الخصوصا في
الخرطوم
مجموعات جديده من من يعني اقصد ان هناك
مجموعات مسلحه متواجده في الخرطوم ربما
وغيرها يتم الحديث ربما عن
المشاهده الان هذا القصف القوي لان ربما
في احد في احدى المناطق في العاصمه
الخرطوم
قصف اربم صاروخي من طائره
مسجل الان هذا التطور النوعي الان على
شاشه العربيه من خلال تغطيتنا اذا وتيره
هذه
المواجهات والاشتباكات تتسارع
سالم هل تسمعني
ربما قصفا بطائره بقصف صاروخي لاحد لاحدى
المناطق هل يمكن الحديث ان اي منطقه
تحديدا تم استهدافها
[موسيقى]
ايضا قذف بهذه الطائرات قصف في هذه
الطائرات لمناطق مختلفه كذلك
لا توجد تفاصيل كثيره جدا لان بدايه القصف
وصوت المضادات ترى الشارع السوداني خاليا
تماما من الماره الان الشوارع خاليه تماما
لا يوجد بها اي احد حتى لا كنت سالتك ان
كان هناك اي اطراف او جماعات مسلحه
بدا تسجيل دخول لها في هذه المواجهات
تحديدا في داخل الخرطوم ربما لترجيح كفه
على اخرى في هذه الحاله من الاصطفاف هل
يمكن الحديث عن هكذا تطور سالم
نعم المسلحه
الموقع السلام هنا في الخرطوم المتواجده
في الخرطوم هي تقف في موقف الحياد لم
تشارك في هذه العمليات على
المسلحه ولا الدعم السريع
وانما هي كانت تدعو الى احكام صوت العقد
العقل وايقاف هذه
المواجهات لان الجميع خاسر فيها بحسب وصف
هذه الحركات هذا الامر جاء على لسان اكثر
من زعيم من زعماء هذه الحركات المسلحه فهي
لم تشارك في هذه
الحرب على الاطلاق وانما هي ظل اعلى حالها
منذ اندلاعها بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وبين قوات الدعم
اذا نحن نحن نتابع نستمع بين الحين والاخر
الى دوي قصف ربما مدفعي وكذلك قصف ربما
بالطائرات يستهدف بعض المناطق في العاصمه
الخرطوم وحسب طبعا ما قاله مراسل العربيه
قبل قليل هناك اشتباكات مستمره في محيط
سلاح المهندسين بيوم درمان وهناك ايضا
قصف جوي يعني قبل قليل شاهدناهم على
الشاشه استهدف منطقه المنطقه المركزيه
ومنطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم التي يتواجد
بها
قصر الرئاسي او مقر القياده العامه للجيش
في العاصمه السودانيه نشاهد ايضا تصاعد
للسنه الدخان في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم سالم مدى عن يعني وضع العاصمه
الان هل يمكن الحديث عن سيطره طرف على اخر
في بعض المناطق من العاصمه دون غيرها
نعم هذه المساله حقيقه صعب جدا ان نتحدث
عنها بهذا الشكل لان السيطره هي الان ليست
على المناطق السكنيه نحن نستطيع ان نتحرك
فقط في المناطق السكنيه ومكان وجود السكان
والشوارع
العاديه يعني البعيده عن المناطق العسكريه
لكن هي الاطراف الان تتصارع على المناطق
السياديه والمناطق العسكريه وهذه صعب جدا
الاقتراب منها لانه محاطه باطواق مبنيه من
الطرفين يعني تكون يعني شبه مستحيل ان تصل
الى تلك المناطق مثلا مطار الخرطوم مثلا
القياده العامه حتى كل المناطق التي نتحدث
عنها الان في فيها الاشتباكات فصعب ان تصل
هذه القوات مركزه على هذه المناطق ترتكز
في هذه المناطق وتركز عليها ويظهر ان لكل
طرف من هذه الاطراف له قصه مع المنطقه
التي يح تد حولها
القتال ان هنالك اهداف معينه يريد ان يصل
اليها كل طرف من هذه المنطقه بالذات
طيب
اذا ما زالت مشاهدينا الكرام المواجهات
مستمره كانت هناك هدنه مقترحه من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بعد اتصال مع قائد قوات
الدعم السريع بعد ذلك قائد قوه الدعم
السريع سيد حميدتي قال بان الجيش لم يحترم
وقفه اطلاق النار وقصف مناطق سكنيه شكرا
جزيلا لك سالم الهاشم راس العربيه كانوا
معنا من الخرطوم نتابع معكم الان في
تغطيتنا المستمره عبر شاشه العربيه هذه
المشاهد المباشره الانفجارات قويه بالقرب
من مقر القياده العامه للجيش في وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم اصوات لاطلاق نار متقطعه
من عده مناطق يرجاء العاصمه السودانيه
بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي كذلك نستمع اليه
بيننا الحين والاخر في
مواجهات واشتباكات تستمر رغم الحديث عن
هدنه كان اقترحها وزير الخارجيه الامري كي
في اتصال جمعه بقائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حماتي
من رياض محمد جميل احمد الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني سيد محمد مرحبا بكم يتم الحديث
الان عن اتساع رقعه المواجهات زياده حده
الاشتباكات سجلنا قبل قليل قصفا صاروخيا
ربما لمحيط مقر القياده العامه للجيش في
الخرطوم رغم الحديث عن هدنه كان اقترح
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في اتصال مع محمد
حمدان حميتي كيف تقرا هذه التطورات سيد
جميل اهلا وسهلا استاذ خالد صباح الخير
نترحم على الارواح الضحايا والمصابين اسال
الله لهم الشفاء انا اعتقد الان الواقع
واقع معقد جدا
والصراع الذي بين الرجلين صراع يعني كما
لو انه صراع كسر عظم يعني بالتالي هذه
الاونه لا يمكن ان تسفر عن اي امكانيه
لتوافق بينهما على التهدئه لكن يبدو اذا
مضت الامور باتجاه الفراط العقد او يعني
باتجاه تفاقم الاوضاع الى يعني افاق خطيره
جدا ربما تكون ضغوط الدوليه تلعب دورا في
الاوضاع او اذا طرف من الاطراف شعره بانه
اصبح ضعيفا او
تم الضغط عليه كثيرا ربما بعد ذلك يصار
الى يعني البحث عن تهدا بينهما ولكن الان
يبدو ان كل ان كل من رجلين مصمم على يعني
القضاء على الاخر
يعني هل يمكن تحديد المسؤول عن افشال هذه
الهدنه خاصه في ضوء عدم وجود رد من الجيش
او ما قيل بان اصل القوات الدعم السريعه
اصبحت مفككه
ليست قادره على الاتصال بين قياداتها
المتواجده في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مناطق
المواجهه
ربما يكون ذلك كما قلت يعني لكن حتى الان
نحن نسمع يعني بيانات متضاربه اخبار
مضاربه ادعاءات مضاربه لكن حتى الان ليس
هناك يعني جهات محايده يعني تضعنا امام
الحقيقه لكن كان واضح جدا انه الخلاف ما
بين الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش في عمليه
الاصلاح الامن والعسكريه التي فاقمت
الاوضاع كان واضح جدا يعني ان يشقه بعيده
يعني ان هناك ابتعاد كبير ما بين الطرفين
يعني مع انه اصلا هو الدعم السريع وشكلهم
اشكال يعني
شكل موارد للجيش يعني هو اصلا في تقديري
الدعم السريع هو شكل من اشكال يعني اثار
تطبيقات ايدولوجيه الاسلام السياسي
الاسلام السياسي يحدث انقسامات داخل اي
دوله يحكمها وبالتالي كان واضحا انه
البشير لما انشا الدائم السريع انشاه فقط
لكي يحميه من الجيش فهذا الوضع نفسه باحد
بهذا وضع انه
هذا المازق يبدو انه اشكاليه كبيره
وبالتالي يعني الان
يعني تتضارب الاخبار يعني هل الذي كان
السبب هو الدعم السريع في تفاقم الاوضاع
او الجيش لكن كثير من الروايات
بتقولها لانه مثلا يوم السبت الماضي
الحدث الاول كان هو محاصره معسكر الصوبه
للدعم السريع
يعني انا اعطيكم ربما يعني
معلومات من طرفي
حتى الساعه 6:00 صباحا يوم السبت الماضي
كان هناك اجتماع كبير
بين الرباعيه
والبرهان
وحميتي سيد جميل لكنه يريد فقط ان اشير
الى هذه التطورات الان نستمع الى قصف
وقصف مدونه متقطع في بعض المناطق وما زالت
اعمده الدخان ترتفع في سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم
اصوات طلق الناري وكذلك قضايا في المدفعيه
ما زالت ايضا تتوالى وتتسارع خلال دقائق
القليله الماضيه تفضل سيد جميل كان هناك
اجتماع يوم السبت نفسه ما بين الرباعيه
والبرهان وحمايتي والقوه السياسيه وتم
الاتفاق على ان تكون لجنه
تقود عمليات التخفيض التصعيد او تخفيض
التوتر وهذا
ادريس اللي هو عضو السياده لكن للاسف
بعد الساعه الثالثه صباحا
جاء اتصال الرباعيه من الدعم السريع يفيد
بانه تم حصار معسكر سوبا الدعم السريع
وللاسف الشديد بعد ذلك الاوضاع تطورت الى
ما لا تحمل الاوضاع يعني اعتقد انه يعني
كان هناك نيات مبيته يعني ويبدو ان الواضح
في الامر انه هناك غاده كبار في الجيش من
غدر الاخوان المسلمين لهم اراده ولهم نيه
في انه يوتر اوضاع لقطع الطريق على
الانتقال الجيش نعم طيب ساعود الى هذه
النقطه لكن نريد ان تقرا معي الدلالات
الدخول مناطق لم تشهد اشتباكات خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في اليوم الرابع
اليوم في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ماذا يعني ذلك
ربما يعني هذا يعني تحويل مسار المعارك
ربما انه
تجلب الثلاثه ايام من المعارك في اماكن
معينه قد لم تفضي الى شيء فربما تحول الى
اماكن اخرى لكن هذا ايضا يشير الى الاتساع
نطاق الحرب يعني وهذا طبعا مؤشر خطير
المؤشر الى انه كل ما توسات حرب كل ما
هناك كلما اصبحت هناك امكانيه لدخول اطراف
اخرى فيها وما نرجو حتى الان اطراف اخرى
في العاصمه
حرب كل ما كان هناك امكانيه
تفضل كل ما توسع تحر كل ما كان هناك
امكانيه لدخول اطراف اخرى واخشى ان اخشاه
الناس انه يعني ان تتوضا هذا الحرب وتدخل
في اطراف اخرى لانه الدعم السريع عشائريه
يعني وبالاساس ميليشيا مكوناتها كلها من
اسميه واحده غالبا يعني او حتى من ابناء
القبائل وبالتالي كل ما اتفاقنا امر يعني
كل ما انحرف العنوان السياسي للحرب كل ما
اصبحنا امام يعني اشكالات كبيره جدا جدا
بالاضافه الى انه حتى الان هذه الحرب يعني
لم يخرط فيها الشعب السوداني يعني الشعب
السوداني محايد حتى الان بل حتى الحركات
المسلحه عندنا خمسه حركات مسلحه على الاقل
يعني حركه الهادي ادريس حركه
جبري ابراهيم ان هذا الحجر الطائر هذه
كلها حركات حتى الان محايده وهي ايضا
موجوده في الخرطوم وجود يعني عساكرها
وجيوشها وقوتها المسلحه موجوده في الخرطوم
وهذه حركات المفارقه ايضا هي يعني يعني من
نفس المنطقه المنطقه التي حدث من الدعم
هذا كله يؤشر الى انه حتى الان هناك
امكانيه لاحتواء هذه الحرب لانه هي الحرب
هذه عباره عنف سياسي وليس حرب اهليه سياسي
ما بين فصيلين كائنات فصيله واحده يعني
وكان رديف للقوات المسلحه لكن من يملك
القدره على احتواء هذه الحربه والمواجه او
التصريحات الاتهامات
المتبادله بين طرف
واضح جدا انه لا يمكن لاحد في الداخل ان
يحكم هذا الحرب الذي يحتوي هذا الحرب هي
ضغوطات الخارجيه وبالتحديد الرباعيه
الرباعيه المجموعه الرباعيه المكونه من
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه والامارات
والبريطانيا هي التي بالاضافه المجتمع
الدولي والامم المتحده التي يمكنها ان
تحدث فرقا في هذا يعني ضغوط الدوليه
بالاضافه الى جهود الاتحاد الافريقي ايضا
مفوضيه الافريقيه هذه التي يمكن ان
اختراقا لكن
ليس هناك اي امكانيه
لاحتوائه حرب داخليه سياسيه اقوى مدنيه
ليس لها امكانيه
مناشده ودعاوى بالاضافه الى انه الحركات
المسلحه ايضا هي الان في الحياد بالتالي
الامر صعب جدا جدا يعني الامر صعب جدا
ومن تصريحات كل من البرهان وحماتي نحن
شاهدنا طبعا كلام حميتيه عن حرب وعن
البرهان
وكان واضح جدا انه الاحتقان وصل ذروه
كبيره جدا وبالتالي يبدو ان من كان قرار
الحرب لينوا يعني انهائها في هذا الامر
القريب يعني الا ان تكون هناك تغض دوليه
يعني نوعيه اختراق يعني وفي تقديري
الولايات المتحده الان هي التي تملك هذا
هذه الامكان
له موقف ملفت وتبعه ايضا اتصال من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكان
بمحمد حمدان حميد قائد قوات الدعم السريع
البيت الابيض كان قد طلب بوقف هذه الحرب
فورا كما اقل بالتالي
الى اي مدى يمكن الولايات المتحده ان تلعب
دورا مؤثرا الان في في ايقاف هذه المواجهه
او في تثبيت حاله تهودنا ربما حتى الان هي
فاشله يعني لمده 24 ساعه
نعم انا اعتقد الان المتحده هي التي يعني
يمكن ان ترشح ان تلعب دورا كبيرا
والولايات المتحده لها امكانيه لذلك لا
امكانيه لانها الحرب خاصه وان هذه المنطقه
يعني السودان منطقه
جيوسياسيه منطقه جيوس استراتيجيه
تنعكس من خلالها تدعيه حرب في البطن كلها
بالاضافه لانه هناك ايضا نفوز روسي في
افريقيا الوسطى وهي الدوله المجاوره
للسودان مباشره يعني هذه النقطه قد تصاحب
اي حاله مدن اوروبا
في اوكرانيا تلعب دور كبير جدا جدا في
العلاقه ما بين المصلح الروسيه او التناقض
والاساسي ما بين المصلح الروسيه والمصلحه
الامريكيه السودان بهذا الشكل يعني هو
واقف هذا البور او في هذا المركز بالتالي
اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده لا تنتظر
طويلا يعني
لن تنتظر طويلا ويبدو انه هناك قرار دولي
يمنع من التسارع الحرب بالطريقه التي قد
تؤدي الى انفجارها على نحو كبير يعني
جميل سنتابع مره اخرى هذا الفيديو
للانفجار الضخم الذي
قبل قليل محيط مقر القياده العامه في وسط
العاصمه السودانيه
اذا تبعنا واياكم في هذا المشهد قبل قليل
قصف قوي وانفجار ضخم تبعه بعد استهداف
الطائره ربما بصاروخ لاحد المناطق المحيطه
حسب مراسل العربيه
بالقياده العامه للجيش السوداني بالخرطوم
بجانب جسر ربما يربط هذه المنطقه بمنطقه
اخرى هنا اعود اليك سيد جميل حول هذا
التطور الان كيف يمكن قراءته بهذا
الاستهداف بهذه القوه الان
في اطار تصاعد وتيره المواجهات
والاشتباكات في العاصمه السودانيه
يبدو ان استهداف مقر القياده العامه هو
عنوان هذا الحرب بمعنى انه يعني
الان غالبا البرهان العامه
ويبدو ان حميتي الذي كان واضح من بدايه
الحرب قال انه ليس في حرب مع الجيش وانما
هو في حرب مع ضباط في الجيش ارادوا قطع
الطريق الانتقال السياسي حسب كلامه يعني
بالتالي
كل الرجلين الصبغ الاحداث لكي يعني يقضي
احدهما على الاخر وبالتالي التركيز الضرب
الانفجارات والضرب على القياده العامه
بعنوان رئيسي لهذا الحرب يبدو واضحا الهدف
منه التعجيل او التسريع بانهاء الحرب من
قبل الجيش هذه طائره
طائره تابعه للجيش تملك مثل هذه الطائرات
الان يعني التي تستخدمها في هذه الحرب
وبالتالي هذا يعني ان هناك تواجد ربما
لقوات حميتي في هذه المنطقه منطقه القياده
العامه للجيش في تواجد كبير لها قوات
حمايه حتى حتى قوات حميته انهت غالبيه
وجود في مناطق شرق السودان مناطق وسط
السودان واتجهت كلها نحو الخرطوم بمعنى
انه حتى في الخرطوم انت لو تلاحظ يعني حتى
شاشات شاشات التلفزه كلها تركز على هذه
المنطقه منطقه هذا العامه التي هي منطق
المركزيه المركزيه
بؤره هذا الص وهي طبعا على اقوال كثيره
يتواجد فيها البرهان وبالتالي يبدو ان
حماتي يريد ان يكسب الحرب او جوله من
الحرب باحداث اختراق في هذا المنطقه
وهذا الذي يفسر لنا هذا اصرار كبير في
التجديد
الدائم للصراع في هذه المنطقه
لماذا برايك لم
حماتي طبعا نحن ممكن نرجع لانه في نقطه
مهمه جدا نعود لها حمتي كان غزاره موسكو
في 24 فبراير 2022
اي في يوم الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي كان حمايه بهذا يعني بهذا السلوك
يعني اخترق يعني مجالا خطير جدا جدا في
الولايات المتحده قاده ضغوط كبيره على
حمايتي
وجعلته يقبل
بالدمج طبعا من اول كان يعني كانت دمج
القوات الدعم السريع بالنسبه خط احمر لكن
زياره حمايه الموسكو في 24 فبراير 22 نفس
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه هذا يعني
تكسب ضغطها
تجنح الى التسويه تجعل حميدتي
يقبل بثلاث اشياء يقبل
بالدمج لانه هذا كان من المحرمات
ويقبل ايضا بان يرجع الى دارفور ويفسط
الامن لانه
ويقبل ايضا يعني بان يكون بدون نفوذ او
ينسحب العمليه السياسيه ونحن راينا ان
المول اللي في اللي هي مبعوصه الخاليه
امريكيه كان جاءت في الصيف الماضي
وتقضى على حميتي وبعد
ذهاب مؤلف فيه اعلى برهان في يوم اربعه
يولي الماضي انسحاب الجيش من عمليه
السياسيه وبعضه تبعه حمايه واعلن صحاب
الجيش انسحاب
بالتالي حمايه الان
هو نتيجه التسويه التي حدثت له مع الضغوط
الدوليه والان خارج يعني خارج العمليه
سياسيه الذين يريدون ويحاول تثبيت موقف او
وضع يضمن له مستقبل
وجهه نظرك لكن نريد ان نتحدث الان بعد هذه
الخلفيه الذي عن التطورات المتسارعه التي
تحدث في في هذه المواجهات فقط اريد ان هنا
ان نشير الى هذه الصور التي وردتنا قبل
قليل تظهر الجيش السوداني معلنا سيطره على
سيطرته على مدينه نيالا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور متابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه السيطره سيد الجميل على هذه المنطقه
نيالا في ولايه جنوب دارفور هي التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع هذه المنطقه لكن هل
اعقبت مواجهات عنيفه ام هي نتيجه لتحرك
قوات
الدعم السريع تجاه المركز الرئيسي ربما
المحوري للصراع والمواجهات في العاصمه
السودانيه طبعا هي المدينه الثانيه في
دارفور وطبعا هي خلفيه خلفيه الاجتماعيه
ودعم السريعي دارفور كلها ويبدو هذا جزء
من عمليه الكرب يعني احيانا حمايه يسيطروا
احيانا يعني الجيش السوداني كما نرى كما
في مره وشاهدناه في المطار
وفي مبنى التلفزيون فاعتقد هذا في سياق
الحرب حرب
لا في سياق حرب يعني يعني ياتي الجيش
ويسيطر يهجم الدعم السريع ويسيطر هكذا لكن
الفاشر اللي هي العاصمه الكبيره يبدو هم
يبدو انه الدعم السريع الفاشر
اعود الى الى موضوع الاتصال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي واقتراح الهدنه ثم موقف
محمد حمدان حميدتي الذي حمل الجيش مسؤوليه
فشل هذه الهدنه بعد ان قال بانه هو من قصف
وهو من استهدف المباني السكنيه
هذا الاتصال جاء بعد مجموعه تغريدات قام
بها قائد قوات الدعم السريع باللغه
الانجليزيه
وكان قد ناشد فيها بتدخل المجتمع الدولي
بشكل سريع
لمعالجه هذه الازمه اذا ما اخذناها في هذا
السياق يعني ان حميتي وقوات الدعم السريعه
اصبحت في وضع
يعني صعب عسكريا خلال هذه المواجهات
وبالتالي لا بد من تدخل ربما ليثبت موقف
يستفيد منه هدنه لاعاده التموضع ربما
واعاده الامداد لقوته الموجوده هذا صحيح
هذا صحيح لكن طبعا سريع هي قوامها مئه الف
يعني ولها اعتاد بحسب المغارات المعروفه
لها عدد كبير يعني لكن قوات الدوله تفتقر
الى الطيران ليس لها طيران
ويوم امس كان واضح جدا انه تدخل الطيران
بصوره قويه جدا ويبدون اراد ان يستبق
المجتمع الدولي
وان يدعوا الى الدخول كما الدولي لكي يخفف
من ضغط الطيران الحربي الذي كان له دور
حاسم في يعني
يعني في ضرب قواعد حميتي فحمتي فعلا يعني
لما
داعي للتدخل كان يستبق هذا الامر يعني كان
يشعر بانه ربما انه معركه الطيران الجوي
هي التي ستحصل الامور لكن يبدو حتى الان
يعني صباح اليوم الان في خبر انه
الدعم السريع يعني احتل مطار الخرطوم مره
اخرى
امس كان في انه قدامها مطار مر لكن
بالعوده
لمهااتفت بلنكن لحمايه هذا يبدو واضح انه
ربما انه حميتي هو الذي طبعا هو يرفع شعار
انه هو مع تحول الديمقراطي
ومع الانتقال السياسي السلام
ويلمح لانه الذين حول برهانهم مجموعه من
اخوهم المسلمين ونحن نعرف اخاصمين وهي
مجموعه مرفوضه اقليم ودوليين وبالتالي
حمايه يريد ان يصور حرب ايضا كما لو انها
صراع يعني يعني صراع ما بين مجموعه
الاخوان المسلمين التي تريد ان تستعيد
السلطه هذه السلطه التي سر عليها الشعب
بصوره كبيره في 2019 ويصور نفسه كما انه
حاملتي تم اطبعه التسويه التسويه التي
اجبرته نتيجه لدارته نتيجه
لجرائم كان ارتكبها في دارفور هذه كلها
يصطف
مع القوه السياسيه ويصطفى عن التقالد
الاماراتي بكره على ذلك التالي حميد الان
يحاول ان يجير هذه المكالمه
مع وزير خارجيه امريكيه كما قلنا كما لو
انه اطفاء للشرعيه عليه نحن نعرف انه يعني
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لم يتصل بالبرهان
يعني
فهذا اشاره واضحه جدا الى انه
حميدتي يعني يلمح الى انه له قبول دولي
اكثر من البرهان شكرا جزيلا لك محمد جميل
احمد الكاتب الصحفي السوداني شكرا
الروايات المتضاربه من الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه فادت الاخيره سيطرت
على مطار الخرطوم الدولي في العاصمه
السودانيه مع اندلاع اشتباكات مع الجيش
[تصفيق]
الان بمطار
الخرطوم المدني
[موسيقى]
في المقابل نشر الجيش السوداني على صفحته
في تويتر مقطع مصورا لسيطره جنوده على مقر
لقوات الدعم السريع في شارع الغابه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر هذا هو مغرهم الله اكبر الله
اكبر
واحتجاز اجانب اضافه الى استهداف مقر
برنامج الغذاء العالمي كما قال واكد بان
القوات المسلحه ستعمل على تكثيف تامين
السفرات وعلق برنامج الغذاء العالمي في
وقت سابق عمله في البلاد مؤقتا بعد مكتل
ثلاثه من موظفيه في منطقه كبكابيا في شمال
دارفور في الاشتباكات الجاريه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم لنا يعقوب لينا مرحبا
بك تتابعينا هذه التطورات اليوم من الرياض
وبالتاكيد هناك الكثير من يعني الانباء
التي تتحدث عن تسارع حده الاشتباكات ودخول
ربما مناطق الان على خط المواجهات لم تكن
تشهد هذه المواجهات في الايام الثلاثه
السابقه عندما نظرنا الى العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم واتساع هذه الرقعه
للمواجهات والاشتباكات الان بهذا الشكل في
ضوء يعني اتصال كان قد جرى بين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي مع محمد حمدان كيف يمكن
النظر الى هذه التطورات
اهلا بك يا خالد يبدو ان الوضع الان في
السودان يتجه من سيء الى اسوا
الاشتباكات كانت في مقر للدعم السريع
والقياده العامه اي انها مقر عسكريه تتبع
لي الطرفين لكنها الان انتقلت الى وسط
العاصمه هناك تضرر كبير الان الى كثير من
المنشات الحيويه كثير من المنازل هناك
قتله ومصابين وهو امر غايه في الخطوره هذه
الاشتباكات يبدو ان الطرفين لم يلتزما
بالهدنه اعلناه هدنه اول امس ثم امس ولم
يتم الالتزام بها اليوم قرانا ايضا ان
الدعم السريع قرر الالتزام بهدنه لمده 24
ساعه لكن كل هذه الامور لا تبدو على ارض
الواقع نشاهد كثير من المشاهد وقبل قليل
فقط تم قصف منطقه في وسط الخرطوم قريبه من
المستشفيات ومن جسر رئيسي وقريبه كذلك
مكاتب العربيه ونحن نلاحظ ونتابع من هنا
الاوضاع هناك ابراج النيلين وهي منطقه
فيها كثير من المكاتب الاعلاميه من بينها
ايضا مكتب العربيه في الايام الماضيه
تضررت اذا هذا الضرر الان ينتقل ليس فقط
من الاماكن العسكريه انما حتى الى كثير من
المناطق السكنيه
في اخر التحديثات الجيش يقول بانه استطاع
تدمير كل قوات ومعسكرات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم ويسيطر عليها كذلك
في جنوب الخرطوم يتحدثون عن معسكر طيبه
وسوبه في جنوب العاصمه حتى في شمال ام
درمان في الصالحه في جنوبها في كراري في
الجيل ايضا في الخرطوم بحري كلها معسكرات
كانت تستخدم
للتدريب تابعه للقوات الدعم السريعه هذه
السيطره
هل هي التي تدفع ربما الجيش والبرهان لعدم
الرد على اي مقترحات هدنه على الاقل في
الوقت الحالي خوفا او ورغبه اولا في تسجيل
مكاسب على الارض قد تقيه من اي ضغوط ربما
دوليه خلال الفتره القادمه تجعله يقدم
خلال التنازلات لا يرتضيها ربما على الاقل
حاليا نعم خالد الجيش في الحقيقه سيطره
على كثير من مقر الدعم السريع الرئيسي
طبعا من المعلوم ان الدعم السريع كان يعلم
ان الجيش قد يستهدف مقاره وبالتالي تم
استهداف هذه المقار وهناك سيطره كثيره على
عدد من
المعسكرات كذلك على عدد ايضا من
الاماكن مثل المطار الذي قال الدعم السريع
انه استولى على المطار يبدو ان هذه الصور
بثت في اول يوم من بدا الاشتباك هذا الامر
يعني يبدو واضحا لنا الان الان الدعم
السريع يسيطر على القصر الجمهوري يبدو انه
نعم هو متواجد داخل القصر الجمهوري ويبدو
ان الجيش لا يرغب بقصف القصر او بقصف
الدعم السريع المتواجد داخل القصر لذلك هو
الان يقوم بعمليه حصار كما اسماها المحيط
في هذه المناطق وفي مقر القياده العامه
حتى الان القصر بعيد قليلا من القياده
العامه القصف من الدعم السريع استهدف
القياده العامه وشاهدنا فيديو لمبنى
القوات البريه كيف انه احرق بصوره يعني
كبيره لذلك هناك الان استهداف من قبل
الدعم السريع الى مقر عسكريه تابعه للجيش
وبالعكس ايضا ولكن القصر هو الان الدعم
السريع متواجد داخل القصر متواجد ايضا
داخل تلفزيون السودان
ومتواجد في كثير من شوارع العاصمه لكن على
المقابل الجيش سيطر على مقر الدعم السريع
معي هذه الصوره هذه المنطقه قبل قليل كانت
قد استهدفت من خلال الطائره ربما تابعه
للجيش من تملك مثل هذه الطائرات قصفت هذه
المنطقه تحديدا حسب مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي هذه المنطقه في وسط العاصمه يقول
بانها في محيط القياده
هذا هو كبري المسلميه او جسر المسلميه
هي موجوده في الخرطوم هذا الجسر فقط
لتسهيل الحركه والازدحام يعني لا يربط بين
منطقتين يمكن الذهاب مشيا بعيدا من هذا
الجسر لكن على الجهه اليمنى توجد مباني من
بينها مكتب العربيه على الجهه اليسرى توجد
مستشفيات
ومقر حكوميه وغيرها في محيط هذا المكان ان
ذهبت سكنيه بالتاكيد في هذه المنطقه هنا
لا توجد عمارات سكنيه بالتحديد ولكن توجد
مستشفيات وتوجد بعض
المقر التابعه لهيئات حكوميه
وهذه المنطقه طبعا دائما خالد تشهد تواجد
عسكري كبير خاصه حينما تكون هناك
التظاهرات كانت تتواجد فيها قوات عسكريه
الشرطه تقوم باغلاق هذه الجسور لذلك يعني
نحن نقول ان هذه هي منطقه وسط الخرطوم لا
يوجد الان اي حركه في هذه المنطقه التي تش
هد عاده حراك كبير وهي ضجه بالحياه لماذا
لانها لانك ان اردت الاتجاه لمثلا لمنطقه
ام درمان الى منطقه بحري هي منطقه تربط
حتى
الى المواصلات العامه الى مناطق كثيره
يبدو واضحا ان الان الاستهداف ليس فقط على
المقر كما ذكرت لك العسكريه لان هذه
المنطقه لا تتواجد فيها مقر عسكريه
اذا اذا كانت هناك منطقه مستشفيات موجوده
في في هذه الجهه لنكما ذكرت هذا ربما
يجعلنا نعود الى ما قالته لجنه اطباء
السودان بان بعض المستشفيات والمرافق
الصحيه يتم استخدامها كنقاط ارتكاز عسكريه
وهذا يعتبر
جريمه انسانيه كما جاء في بيان لجنه
الاطباء طبعا هذا جاب الاضافه الى ما جاء
ما ذكره ايضا واشار اليه البيان بخروج
مستشفيات ومرافق صحيه عن الخدمه بسبب
القذف لكن هذا هل يبرر ذلك حاله الاستهداف
لهذه المنطقه تحديدا ربما كتحويل هذه
المستشفيات هذه المناطق الصحيه الى نقاط
ارتكاز عسكريه لطرف طبعا خالد يعني هذا
تكتيك عسكري ان يتواجد او ان تتواجد قوات
في مناطق سكنيه في منشات صحيه في غيرها
اعتقادا منها ان القصف لن يطالها في هذه
الاماكن
تكتيك عسكري موجود ولكن هذا القصد الدعم
السريع يعني بحكم انها قادره على التحرك
الداخلي بشكل سريع ربما اكثر من الجيش هل
يمكن القول بانها هي من بالفعل تقوم
باستخدام هذه المستشفيات كنقات ارتكاز
عسكريه وبالتالي تستهدف الان من الجيش ما
اعلمه ان الدعم السريع متواجد في كثير من
المناطق هناك كثير من الفيديوهات التي
تاكدنا منها تظهر بصوره مباشره بان الدعم
السريع او ضباط وجنود الدعم السريع في
متواجدين في كثير من المستشفيات هذا يعني
انهم يتحركون بصوره طبيعيه داخل
المستشفيات داخل كثير من المقر هنا
متواجدين في اماكن ومناطق سكنيه هذا يشير
الى ان هذا الانتشار ليس في اماكن عسكريه
فقط انما وسط المواطنين في الاسواقين
هذه الساعه تغطيه زميل احمد الهادي عود
اليكم مره اخرى على راس السحر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات